[Applaus]
herr präsident verehrte kollegin völlig
klar ist bestehende gesetze sind mit
konsequent anzuwenden und rechtsstaat
mit nachdruck zu verteidigen
dafür steht die fdp heads plattformen
wie in die media bleiben heute
unangetastet und es versagt der staat
und auch zum entsetzen vieler bürger
draußen
auch bei der bekämpfung zb von
kriminellen ausländern al amiri oder
start völlig versagt bei der ausweisung
oder das unwillen des staates seine
grenzen zu schützen
währenddessen haben hier etliche der
redner hate speech im wahrsten sinn des
wortes auf ihren lippen
am meisten aber staunt die ruhe mit der
einschneiden rechtliche änderung von der
gesellschaft von medien politik und
quittiert werden
dabei ist die erosion unseres frei
unserer freiheitlichen demokratie nicht
zu übersehen mit worten beginnt das
etliche städte hier haben hierzulande
den klima notstand erklärt in der letzte
woche erfolgte in dresden der nazi
notstand nun könnte man meinen dass
gerade mit wort den board notstand ein
sensibler umgang angebracht wäre
notstandsgesetze führten nach weimar
direkt in die nazi diktatur das
berüchtigste das ermächtigungsgesetz vom
märz 33
danach wurde das parlament für die
mitwirkung der welt gesetzte obsolet
notstand spaltet die gesellschaft nach
ihrer definition ist gerade das hate
speech
warum tun sie nichts gegen diese
hassrede sie nutzen die von mitte bis
ganz links und in der demokratischen
länder bedeutet null stand in der
regelung die verkürzung des rechtsschutz
gegen staatliche maßnahmen wie an was
hier vorbereitet wird verbote die
einschulung der wirklichen gegenwehr
bedeuten die nutzung von privaten
fahrzeug mit verbrennungsmotor
das bewohnen von mehr als einer noch
festlegen anzahl von quadratmeter
wohnraum
das heizen mit fossilen energieträgern
der erhebung von annähernd kostendeckend
renditeorientierten mieten die
ermöglichen des brauchs gegen windparks
vor meinem haus die an der anspruchnahme
von meinungsfreiheit und bürgerrechte
und all das und noch viel mehr kann
unter umständen wegfallen natürlich nur
alles im sinne einer guten sache die
ebenso natürlich von links definiert
wird
wer dagegen spricht spricht hassrede
bislang landete er dann auf den medien
meldeplattform eines herrn böhme man
doch jetzt hat herr halver den tv clown
böhmermann abgelöst durch den
bundesverfassungsschutz wurde eine
staatliche melde und initiation hotline
eingerichtet
dort erfolgt wie zu finstersten zeiten
die bürger bespitzelung
das kommt davon wenn man einen mann mit
rückgrat wir herrn maßen durch einen
willfährigen bürokraten ablöst der
tatbestand hassrede ist bewusst
unbestimmt gehalten weil man erkannt hat
mit dem vorwurf der verleumdung oder
beleidigung volksverhetzung ist im
freien denken argumentieren der bürger
nicht beizukommen
wenn sie aber nachbarn nun gegenseitig
anzeigen können sogar anonym
und damit für den inserenten folgenlos
haben viele der roten socken und der
überlebende nazi spitzel und weitere
viel erreicht und weil diese inquisition
links ist ist aus ihrer sicht alles
hassreden als rechts zu sehen
und genau das ist ihr denkfehler denn
von professor nadine straßen die
ehemalige position zu merken sympathie
linien argumentierte seit die reaktion
auf spielte in der eu vollkommen falsch
ich zitiere hier egal wie gut gemeint in
der praxis ist das verbot von hate
speech bestenfalls wirkungslos im
schlimmsten fall kontraproduktiv
vorschoss erklärt hast es eine emotion
es gibt kein allgemeingültiges konzept
der hate speech und weiter in westlichen
in der westlichen welt
erscheinen wir erscheint der
grundlegende zusammenhang zwischen
meinungsfreiheit und allen anderen
freiheiten in der gesellschaft vergessen
worden zu sein
weg mit der redefreiheit bedeutet weg
mit der freien gesellschaft und das ist
definitiv nicht im sinne der bürger und
dagegen wenden wir uns als afd
im übrigen ich kann nur sagen die herren
lindner und de maizière haben ja bereits
erfahrung mit was passiert wenn man die
büchse pandora der linken überlässt hate
speech ist im übrigen ein politischer
begriff und kein juristischer
dementsprechendes definition politisch
beliebig und es geht ihnen hier um ein
machtmittel um nicht mehr
denn ansonsten würden sie gegen und ich
zitiere erwiderung in dem fall hate
speech mit faschisten oder aber
nazidreck oder aber was auch den liebl
eine kollegin von den grünen passiert
ist tracks vorzüge an dem fall auch an
das einschreiten
hier ist ganz klar in dem fall eine ganz
klare hinweis pace page ist ganz klar
etwas anderes als eingriff in die
persönlichkeitsrechte
hier geht es um eine politische kampagne
und wir stehen für die freiheit der
bürger und gegen politische kampagne
gegen dem falle die gegen diese von
inszenierte hexen und das abwürgen von
konservativen meinung im
gesellschaftlichen kontext
wir brauchen kein wahrheit - terium
vielen dank